the soccer players rescued from a cave
in Thailand are telling family members
that they only intended to be inside for
one hour
a sudden flood left them stranded for
more than two weeks only on CBS this
morning the father of the youngest boy
spoke with Anna Warner she's in chiang
rai thailand and a good morning good
morning well what is it like to see your
son for the first time in 18 days days
you spent wondering whether you would
ever see him alive again we spoke with
the father of the youngest boy to be
rescued from the cave 11 year old Titan
and asked him just that I was never I
felt relieved I was so happy tonne of
that told us about the moment he learned
his 11 year old son
Titan would be rescued from the cave the
boy was the youngest of the 12 soccer
players trapped for more than two weeks
and little Titan emerged with big
stories to tell Titan told his father
the boys were forced to run deep into
the cave they were exploring when fast
moving water started flowing in he says
the boys soccer coach named ik tried to
swim to find a way out for them but the
water was so fast and so deep he turned
back around Gaytan told his father the
first three days in the cave were the
hardest the group was hungry and cold
the boys had trouble sleeping and tight
and cried because he missed his mom and
dad coach Jack Ogden encouraged him to
be strong Tana Wu told us how do you
feel about what the coach did fear son
listen I am touched he said if the kids
didn't have coach ik I don't know how
they could have survived this is
completely uncharted unprecedented
territory back in London Friday morning
British divers involved in the rescue
said nothing like this has ever been
done before there was a lot of chaos but
we were so task orientated and folk
we blank that out and carried on with
the doping hands step by step until
until we achieve success and taro root
says for that he is thankful I feel so
grateful he said and thankful to all
Thai people and everybody who sent their
love and support Tana will told us Titan
is doing well he says the first thing
his son asked upon getting out of the
cave was where was his coach and how was
he doing Ty health officials tell us by
the way Jon that all the kids are doing
well now mentally and physically and a
Warner in Thailand thanks everything
about this story now there's a kid named
Titan which is just exactly perfect who
comes out and wants to know about the
coach I mean yeah it is a beautiful
story in the end as harrowing as it has
been we are so thankful they're out and
we cannot wait for the movie bond in the
connection that they all share
absolutely two weeks incredible great
interview from Anna